[Music]
hi everybody strap yourself in you're in
for a wild ride today
my guest is none other than michio kaku
who is the father of string
field theory having created it when he
was a
younger lad at the city university of
new york
uh oh so many years ago back when i was
a wee lad
and this paper really set forth a new
type of
era for string theory one that i really
was
ignorant about to be honest with you
this podcast is a little bit strange
because i recorded it once
using software that i shall not name
again
but that recording only captured
my audio and not michio's and so he was
gracious when i groveled and begged
and pleaded please do my audience a
favor of having a
proper video conversation with me one
more time
and he carved out time this book the god
equation
which we discussed pr primarily in this
podcast is a new york times bestseller
and amazon bestseller
he's wanted on all sorts of ephora and
venues
including the colbert report and other
places where he has been
fettered and rightfully so he's a
serious scientist although obviously he
comes off to some people
as uh really promoting beyond the realms
of viability for things like string
theory which have
yet to be proven and we talked about
that in both the podcast
the one that didn't get recorded at
least his audio and video didn't get
recorded very well
so what i'm going to do is make this a a
two-part
episode one will be audio only
and that will be on itunes or spotify or
on my website briankeating.com
go there sign up for my mailing list
while you're at it
and you listen to the audio only
interview
that i did with some really expert
post-processing that really saved my
kosher bacon uh from j yao and others
who work
on podcast extraordinarily hard along
with my producer
super producer stuart walco so anyway
sit back and enjoy the video
episode and then go to the audio only
one it's kind of a companion we go
very deep into competitor theories
theories like loop quantum gravity and
he went off on
on these competitor theories in contra
distinction
uh to some of the things claimed about
string theory by previous guests like
carlo rivelli who will be an upcoming
guest for his new book hegeland
which is coming out in may stay tuned
for that so please subscribe
uh if you're able to follow like do all
sorts of things leave a comment what do
you think about these podcasts
what do you come away as a take away
from michio kaku as he changed your
opinion about string theory about the
god equation
about religion and science or even about
him himself
because i've actually come away with a
deeper appreciation for him
and i hope you'll enjoy the special
two-part episode
with one of the foremost exponents and
proponents
of uh not only string theory but all of
theoretical physics so
sit back and enjoy this episode of the
into the impossible podcast
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast i am your fearful
host
dr brian keating and this is now
professor mitchio kakou's second
appearance on the into the impossible
podcast because
of a mistake by an unknown unnamed uh
podcast software
which i will not repeat but anyway today
is going to be even bigger and better
than ever
because so much has happened just in the
week or so since i first interviewed
michio
and he is so gracious and so kind to
come back
given his busy schedule and his newly
christened
best-selling book the god equation which
is one of my favorite books in recent
memory
michio how are you very good
honored to be on your show it's really
such a pleasure and i want to
congratulate you from all of us in the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination on
not only the success of of the book you
know in terms of commercial success but
in terms of the critical acclaim that it
has received
it's made a tremendous impact and i want
to uh
begin with maybe this version of the
podcast to to
make up for for past uh sins on my part
uh maybe it was a message to me uh do
you believe in
in kind of uh the the mysterious ways of
serendipity michio that maybe this was
for a reason
that we got to go together again for the
second time
well um destiny of course is a very
elusive quantity
but as i mentioned in my speeches i
think i think humanity has a destiny
not individuals but i think humanity has
a destiny the universe is a chess game
and our destiny is to figure out the
rules of chess
and the rules of chess of course give
you the god equation
and then we want to become grand masters
of chess
i think that's the destiny of the human
race to master the rules of chess that
is the god equation
and then to become grand masters and
when
we talk about chess we we actually
didn't have a chance to talk about this
last time but maybe this is a good
time as any to go into this i have a
theory that
we're already being beaten by computers
and artificial intelligences when it
comes to chess
do you think an artificial intelligence
could ever create a game like chess in
other words
does it have the creative power even in
a futuristic alpha infinity type
computer
could it create a game that humans would
find amusing
or or perhaps could create a complex
game not just solve and
beat us but could actually outdo us and
create a game
such as chess well first of all
let's take a look at artificial
intelligence today versus artificial
intelligence maybe in the next century
and beyond
when we look at robots today what
animal are they equivalent to if you
were to compare a robot today to an
animal
they would be equivalent probably to a
cockroach
you could put a cockroach in a forest
and the cockroach would immediately find
food shelter mates you take our most
advanced military
robot and put it in the forest so what
happens
it falls over gets lost can't even get
up again
but eventually they will be as smart as
a mouth then as smart as a rat
then as smart as a rabbit then as smart
as a dog or a cat
and by the end of the century who knows
when i think they'll be as smart
as a monkey now monkeys are self-aware
therefore they are potentially dangerous
as well
and we at that point we should put a
chip in their brain to shut them off if
they have murderous thoughts
now that's because monkeys are
self-aware now dogs on the other hand
dogs are confused you see dogs think
that we are a dog
and that's why they obey us because
there's a picking order
in a wolf pack and that's why they obey
us
so we have a long ways to go i think
before we have a a device that is as
creative
and as spontaneous and innovative
as human beings and so michio one thing
i thought of after we talked the last
time
that maybe serendipity gives us another
chance to discuss
is that um i think of you as a master
storyteller
and people you know that you have a
wonderful reputation as a hardcore
scientist
but i interviewed in the intervening
weeks since we spoke
i interviewed a neil degrasse tyson and
he and i spoke about many things
including
impact of race and issues of race etc
but but mainly about science and
popularization
as well as the fact that he can no
longer walk down the street and not get
recognized
uh the day after you and i record our
episode uh you and i appeared together
in william shatner's unexplained the
episode about the moon
and i was just remarking to one of my
kids came in and said wow
dad you're you're really important look
look how look who you're appearing with
and i said who captain kirk william
shatner he said no michio kaku
how do you take your fame and celebrity
how do you handle it and still do
serious work
when you know that some physicists look
down on those of us who reach out to the
public how do you see the balance
between your public persona
on tv and movies uh with uh with your
private
productive persona as a physicist
well there's a sad story about carl
sagan the greatest genre
he of course was a publishing astronomer
made contributions to the field of
astronomy
made discoveries however he was
nominated for the national academy of
sciences
that's the nation's highest scientific
advisory body it advises the united
states congress for example
but the mathematicians at yale revolted
and when the vote was taken they
basically said he is a quote
mayor popularizer and they voted him
down
and that was kind of an embarrassment to
carl sagan
but now we have figures like stephen
hawking
who have impeccable credentials as a
research scientist
and so they're in a situation where they
can say yes i want to reach
the people i'll be able to touch
people's hearts
and minds because of course ultimately
who pays our salary it's the taxpayers
ultimately
and you know during the cold war all we
had to do was go to congress and say one
word
one word that would get funding and that
word was russia
then congress would come back to us with
two words
and those two words were how much well
those days are gone
we have to learn to sing for our supper
and that was very dramatic in my field
elementary particle physics and
relativity in the 90s when the
supercollider was canceled
that's the reason why american particle
physics is two
generations behind europeans because
there of course
they have the large hadron collider what
happened during those hearings
well in the in the last days of hearing
one congressman asked a physicist and i
quote
will we find god with your machine
if so i will vote for it well the poor
man didn't know what to say
so he said we'll find the higgs boson
well you can hear the jaws hit the floor
of the united states congress
billions of dollars for another god damn
subatomic particle
the vote was taken and the machine was
cancelled and since then we physicists
have wracked our brains
how should we have answered that
question because it'll come up again
will we find god with your machine i
would have answered it
differently i would have said god
by whatever signs or symbols you ascribe
to the deity
this machine the supercollider will take
us
as close as humanly possible to his
greatest creation
genesis this is the genesis machine
it will celebrate the greatest day in
the history of the universe
it's birth unfortunately we said higgs
boson
and american particle physics
experimental physics was set back
two generations think about that
so we physicists have to learn to sing
for our supper
as we talked about last time there is an
awful lot of god that makes its way into
things like the god particle which i
think it was a pejorative originally for
the god
you know hyphen d am and particle
by letterman uh but but i wonder you
know
if if there isn't a metal layer on a
higher level
this this feeling that um when you
cancel something the money goes back
into the same field in other words there
was a jealousy just as there was of carl
sagan and i heard that story
uh from from people that knew carl
obviously uh but
but also there was almost like a
jealousy of of particle physics that it
enjoyed a whole century or half of a
century at least of
being the most preeminent uh regarded
field of physics
uh we're in physics was the preeminent
form of of intellectual activity
of all human beings at least where you
had people like fine men and others
a schwinger escorted by uh armed guards
to go to physics
meetings like i can't even imagine you
know going to the double a s or the aps
meeting and having an armed guard next
to me i mean that would be kind of fun
actually but
uh but you know towards the end of the
century people start to think well
you know what are we getting what's the
return on investment and uh there have
been you know some books written about
this
peter white has written about this elise
mullen has
written about this how do you answer the
critics that say there haven't been
major revolutions
in fundamental particle physics since
the 1974
what november revolution i think it was
called how do you answer those critics
that say that fundamental physics has
been in a holding pattern
for 50 years almost well
there is a unspoken pecking order
where as you pointed out some people are
jealous that
elementary particle theoretical
physicists are at the top
of the pyramid and computer scientists
call this
physics envy physics envy
meaning that in physics things get
simpler every year but more powerful so
when i write an equation down
i know that on the other side of the
middle qa galaxy
there's an alien with a different
notation
writing the same equation because these
equations are universal
now you can't say that about shakespeare
you can't say that about great works of
art
because of course they're particular to
the planet earth specifically homo
sapiens
on the planet earth in a certain century
in a certain country
with a certain language while physics
especially elementary particle physics
is
universal plus it gets simpler
every year while english literary
criticism
i have a lot of respect for them some of
them are my friends who engage in
english literary criticism they wonder
what did james joyce
really mean by that and phd theses by
the hundreds
are written about what did hemingway
really mean by that sentence
so english literary criticism becomes
more complicated every year
theoretical physics is the opposite you
could put all the
equations of the universe the
fundamental equations on
one sheet of paper one sheet of paper
now can you do that with shakespeare can
you do that with hemingway
no but physics the fundamental laws of
physics can be put on one sheet
of paper top of the line einstein's
equations one
inch long then the standard model which
is
ugly and sin but you can put it on a
sheet of paper the theory of almost
everything
a bunch of gibberish you know 10 lines
across that's the
standard model and it didn't have to be
that way and so that's where physics
envy comes into the picture
if you are a computer programmer
tirelessly working about
computer games or algorithms for wall
street
it gets complicated but physics gets
simpler and more
universal and more powerful as the years
go by
now are people jealous as a consequence
yes
but that's human nature science
progresses
independent of the whims of jealousy and
human nature
so physics will march forward no matter
how jealous people are
or how much backstabbing there is
because that's
human behavior you can't stop it
that's just the way it is for example
when i
got my phd back in the 1970s from the
university of california at berkeley
if you were doing string theory people
laughed at you
they snickered in fact john schwartz was
in
an elevator with richard feynman and
richard feynman was joking with john
schwartz and said
john how many dimensions are you in
today
in other words feynman like to make fun
of everybody especially string theorists
and so the point of raising is we are
humans
therefore we engage in pretty kinds of
behavior but let me tell you my favorite
feynman story
i give a talk on stringfield theory
which is my creation
it summarizes all string theory in an
equation about one inch long
and i gave a talk at aspen for the
center of theoretical physics
feynman and gelman two giants were
in the audience feynman being famous for
putting down
the speaker finding comes up to me after
my talk
and he says well i don't necessarily
agree with string theory
but then he said your talk was one of
the most beautiful talks
i have ever heard in other words
summarizing this
vast treasure trove of equations
of string theory into an equation that
is one
inch long he said your paper was
gorgeous
well that's high price indeed i'm gonna
come back with a retort
uh from feynman himself which is that uh
he said
i don't care how beautiful your theory
is if it doesn't agree with experiment
it's wrong and you lost a bet a few
years ago with a commentator john horgan
uh so-called bet over the uh string
theory
uh provability before 2020. no the nobel
prize with the nobel prize
nobel prize yeah i forgot what did i say
well ignore what i said but anyway you
made a bet
uh under the auspices of the long bets
foundation a public arena
uh that it would be and there would be
evidence uh
for uh for either super string theory of
membrane theory of some other unified
theory describing all the forces of
nature
that would result in a nobel prize so
you lost that bet you paid up
uh of course uh unlike some other people
who didn't pay up certain bets but we're
not going to talk about those people
so i want to ask you in line of
fineman's saying um
how long do we would you make that bet
again would you make a 10-year
long bet with me uh how do you feel
about the prospects for
uh i mean i don't like the nobel prizes
these posters will tell you
as a kind of a sign of god's you know
kind of divinity bestowed upon mankind
because it's just given out by mortals
mainly in sweden uh and so who are they
to judge us but but anyway
i want to ask a question um are the
prospects getting bigger or would you
dispute that quote with feynman
that that the cinequan none is
experimental testability
no i agree with richard feynman and also
carl sagan
carl sagan said remarkable claims
require remarkable proof
and two weeks ago there was an
earthquake that emerged outside chicago
at fermi laboratory
an earthquake that everyone is talking
about in physics
experimental or theoretical a deviation
has been found
in the standard model look i got my phd
in 1972. the standard model was already
in place
when i got my phd and it held sway for
50 years for 50 years we have not seen
no crack in the standard model
even though it's the ugliest theory ever
proposed in the history of science
36 quarks and antique quarks three
generations of identical particles
three parameters that can be adjusted at
will it's ugly
it is clumsy it's a theory that only a
mother could love
and crack in it just two weeks ago
people are jumping on it we have four
forces we have gravity
the electromagnetic force and the two
nuclear forces there could be
a fifth force a fifth force
could emerge from the fermi laboratories
outside chicago
and that's causing excitement and what
are the candidates for a fifth force
well it means a new particle string
theory has lots of particles
we here uh in this universe of ours we
are the lowest octave of the string
in fact if einstein had never been born
we would have discovered generalitivity
as the lowest vibration of a string
however the string has higher octaves
just like your piano
just like your violin is higher octave
the higher octaves could be manifested
who knows for sure
in this new discovery plus we have
satellites going up
lisa a gravity wave detector in outer
space that may detect
evidence of a pre big bang universe
predicted by string theory
not to mention the fact that the chinese
the
japanese and the europeans are now
proposing a successor to the large
hazard collider
which may very well probe the periphery
of string theory
not to mention the fact that there are
ongoing experiments right now
testing for deviations from newton's
laws of gravity as
predicted by string theory so in other
words there are plenty
of experiments that are now being
conducted
the people who don't know this are the
critics
right you know i was taking the
opportunity between the previous time we
converse till today to look at
some of your papers from the 1970s and i
found them remarkably
prescient uh for those that uh you know
have any doubt of michio's calculational
computational prowess uh
you've been at the new york uh at cuny
for a long time i didn't realize how a
lot that you
were there since 1974 after getting your
phd
you work with mandelstam right as your
advisor yeah that's right
so you are a proponent and what i
thought we'd do this time
uh is talk a little bit with you uh
playing the role
of the of the of the defender of
rivals to string theory in other words
i'm going to pretend i am the proponent
of string
theory and i'm kind of agnostic i'm an
experimentalist i like to
adhere to experimental tests obviously
and even the cosmological tests we'll
get into that in a bit
but i'm going to say act as the defender
and i want you to kind of
support pick a theory that's a rival in
your mind it could be loop quantum
gravity
it could be my friend eric weinstein's
geometric unity
what do those theories have that can
rival the lagrangian
which you made not only the first
relativistic
field theory thereof but you wrote down
lagrangian that included matter fields
so
these other models that you support in
this argument uh
in simulated uh space you support loop
quantum gravity and other things they
don't even include fermions so
what can you say about these rivals to
string theory to defend them
well first of all what is the criterion
for to win a nobel prize and be declared
the next einstein
you have to satisfy three things three
things
and you will go down in history as the
next einstein
your theory your lagrangian must first
of all have
general relativity in it second it must
have the standard model
and more but at least the standard model
third it has to be mathematically
consistent that is finite
and anomaly free that's it
and then the question is how many
theories can
satisfy these criterion let's take them
one at a time
there's something called loop quantum
gravity a very ingenious theory i must
admit
however it has no electrons
no protons you and me were not part of
loop quantum gravity
it's a theory of pure gravity
and pure gravity is probably
mathematically inconsistent
if you calculate the first feynman loop
diagram i'm pretty sure
it is divergent we've done it on
computers
we haven't done it in the regime for
glute plan of gravity
but for perturbative gravity we've done
it on a computer
and it diverges it blows up it's
infinite
well what about all the other attempts
erwin schrodinger
tried to create a unified field theory
he's the founder of quantum mechanics
for god's sake
he failed he thought that it was again a
pure gravitational theory
no electrons no protons and so you go
down the list
and then you begin to realize oh my god
there's nothing left
except one and the only thing that is
left is
string theory now if you don't like
string theory what is your main
attack your main attack against string
theory would be as follows
first is it a theory of anything
or a theory of nothing or a theory of
everything
in other words where is the beef where
is the experimental proof
and i have a rebuttal to that second
it doesn't predict our universe it
predicts a multiverse
of universes and which one is ours
so a theory of everything becomes a
theory of
anything and so it has no predictive
power
you cannot predict anything a priority
using string theory so those are the two
most powerful arguments against string
theory
which i will be glad to address yeah and
i will
further attack uh i will further attack
a loop quantum gravity
by by just saying that the the
foundation in which it's based and maybe
this is
a technical point but my understanding
is that there are hamiltonian
formulations of it but not lagrangian
formulations or perhaps those don't
exist can you specify or explain why is
that an important distinction
when you say the lagrangian of string
theory that you worked on
from the 1970s until today um is the
syna is the kind of the
necessary uh you know ingredient of of a
of a starting point for a universal
theory of everything
can you say why the loop quantum gravity
should even be considered given that it
doesn't have
a you know fully fleshed out standard
model of particle forces and fields
well why is it that relativity and the
quantum theory
don't like each other why should god
have a left hand
and a right hand that fight each other
that don't coordinate
i mean that's ridiculous why would god
create two hands that don't coordinate
with each other
well the problem is that gravity is
based on smooth surfaces
smooth elegant beautiful gorgeous
manifolds
well matter is based on chopped up
particles that you grind up and spit out
like a meat grinder it's all cut up and
so loop quantum gravity
which in which field does it fall into
it falls into the gravity field
but says nothing about electrons protons
quarks mesons the hundreds of scientists
the hundreds of particles that we have
analyzed
nothing about it it's a theory of pure
gravity
and therefore it is simply not a unified
field theory
which even the creators of the theory
acknowledge
they'd be the first ones to say that
their theory is not a rival
the string theory it's just an
alternative an alternative for gravity
but not for electrons protons quarks
you and me basically and so we have a
situation
where of all the theories proposed these
two theories relativity and
quantum theory don't like each other
when it's based on smooth manifolds
like trampoline nets and the other one
is based on chopped up
particles and how do you combine these
two
the only way to combine these two is
through music
and that is the lowest octave of the
string contains all of einstein's theory
if einstein had never been born we would
have discovered the entirety of general
relativity
as the lowest note of a vibrating string
which is i think amazing in fact the
standard model
is also there among the lowest octave
the problem is
everything else is there too universes
that don't exist
universes where protons are unstable and
matter cannot form
universes that are different dimensional
they're all there in string theory
how does it select out our universe out
of this
wide range of universes i'll answer that
in a moment
right yeah so for me one question i've
come up with i've spoken to
many many proponents of string theory
from kamran baffa
john preskill others and you know the
question i keep getting
not so satisfied by their answers i'm
going to pose to you which is that
it's not at all clear that uh that
having somebody like my former guest
liner and susquehanna on
saying that there's a landscape of
possible vacuous states
and this is tall to me as an
experimentalist to imply
an almost unbounded number of possible
string theories string values of
fundamental constants
values of masses of the fermionic sector
the bosonic sector
you go you can describe in any way you
like it can
construct a landscape of possible of
universes
that we find ourselves just in one and
there's always the anthropic
kind of uh result that that that then
implies but it's not all clear to me
michio and maybe you can
um you know you can clarify for me but
why would these law
other universes not also have laws where
one plus one doesn't equal two because
what they call
addition is what we call quaternionic
multiplication
in other words that the laws of math the
loss of logic why couldn't they differ
from universe to universe in the string
landscape
well let me try to answer this question
by answering by
posing another question how many
solutions of newton's laws
are there newton lived in the 1600s
how many solutions are there there's a
solution for a gun
for a rocket ship or a pellet a marble a
spinning top
in fact they're an infinite number
there's a landscape
there's a landscape of infinite sequence
of solutions to
newton's laws of gravity maxwell's
equations for life
how many solutions of maxwell's
equations are infinite number
so how do you determine which one is
your universe
you have to tell me you have to tell me
that we're describing a rocket today
or we're describing the empire state
building today you have to tell me this
you have to tell me quote the initial
conditions okay
same thing if i have a theory of
everything not string theory but an
alternative
if i have an alternative theory of
everything it has the same problem
it will give you an infinite number of
solutions depending on
your initial conditions so where do the
initial comes where did the initial
conditions come from
you tell me now at the instant of
creation we're talking about 10 to the
minus
33 centimeters with the flying
length of energy that's the energy of
the big bang itself
the universe started off as a quantum
flow situation
in the vacuum now given that
fact what are the initial conditions at
the instant of creation
we don't know that's an experimental
problem that's for you guys
that's where the weak link is
experimental physics when the
experimental physicists tell us
that we're talking about a spinning top
uh
a bullet a rocket ship there would be an
equation
but until the experimentalists tell us
what the initial conditions of the
universe were
we're stuck because that's an
experimental problem
in other words it's your fault right
i'll take the blame for that that's uh
the
least thing i've been accused of today
alone michio but let me refer you to the
work done by
david spurgle daniel holtz maya fishbach
and chris pardo back
in 2018 which is titled limits on the
number of space-time dimensions
from gravitational waves 1708
uh which very severely limited and
constrained the dimensionality
uh to be very close to three dimensions
of space
in contra distinction with an
uncertainty of at the few percent level
from a single event by the way i mean
this will only get better
so does this not rule out vast you know
vast tracts of land many acres in the
string landscape i mean almost
infinitesimally shrinking it to
to a single uh if you like boundary
condition
because as you know newton's laws are
very different in the universe of three
spatial dimensions versus two or one or
four four or five so do these limits
shake your confidence at all in large
extra dimensions or in
in string theory as as a as a whole
no uh these are all speculations i think
these speculations are healthy
but until we have the god equation that
is the final formulation
of string theory all these are nothing
but speculation
now let me explain my equation string
field theory allows you to summarize
string theory into an equation a little
bit more than an
inch long in fact i published it in my
my book
the the the god equation however
that's not enough we now have the 11th
dimension coming in
coming in from princeton's physicist
department and
we know that there are membranes now do
we have a string field theory for
membranes and strings the answer is no
now maybe somebody who's listening to
this program will be inspired
to write down the field theory of
membranes and strings
and i have a word of advice for them
when you find this final equation the
god equation
tell me first we'll publish together
and we'll win the nobel prize together
and we'll be declared as the joint
creators the successors to albert
einstein
because that's what we're talking about
we're talking about the lagrangian
which is probably an inch long which
will summarize
both membranes and strings that could be
the whole shooting match
so uh the other virtue of the work that
you've done is that
um you obviously think geometrically i
remember reading your books in the 90s
and being heavily influenced on them
not quite tempted to become a
theoretician myself but but nevertheless
very uh influenced by you
and the and the exquisite way that you
spoke about
um kind of the two sides of einstein's
equations you know one kind of marble
and one made of wood and and and
thinking about the hyperspace
you know kind of conjectures are those
possible to re to
to rule out with with any experiment you
know as nathan seinberg said
we we strength theorists are very
arrogant if something comes along
and we and is successful we will call it
part of string theory in other words
if by saying that we need to you know
get more and more data
essentially is there a falsifiable
element to string theories or any
experiment or combination
of experiments that would cause you
michio to reconsider
your uh your claim that the god equation
will will ultimately be found in other
words is there is there
hope is it hopeless to convince you
otherwise
or because of your deep-seated
convictions and work in the field
or is there really a chance that string
theory could be wrong
well every theory has to be testable
reproducible and falsifiable
that is what we call science and there
are ways to
test string theory let me just rattle
them off real quick five ways
five possible ways to test string theory
one is to look for deviations in the
standard model
like what happened two weeks ago the
first
major crack in the standard model was
found
maybe it's the fotino or maybe it's a
higher supersymmetric partner
of some of the particles that we see
today predicted
by string theory second lisa laser
interferometry space antenna sponsored
by the european space agency
and nasa we want to get a gravity wave
detector
in outer space giving us baby pictures
baby pictures of the instant of creation
when it emerges from the womb
and if we get baby pictures of the
infant universe emerging from the womb
maybe we'll find an umbilical cord
an umbilical cord because string theory
does not stop
at the instant of creation string theory
goes before
the instead of creation there's a
multiverse of universes out there
and so we can talk about pre big bang
physics how do we do that we look for
post big bang radiation
and then run the videotape backwards
using string theory equations
to get radiation profile from before
the creation of the universe itself
that's number two
number three is dark matter there are
experiments going on right now even as
we speak
looking for dark matter collisions with
protons the spark created by such a
collision will be photographed
and that could signal dark matter on the
earth you see we live in a wind
a wind of dark matter right now there's
dark matter penetrating your body
but it's not electromagnetically charged
so it's very difficult to detect it's
like a neutron very difficult to detect
but any day now i'm not sure when it'll
happen
but we're going to detect evidence of
dark matter in the laboratory
and also dark matter in outer space
fourth we're talking about the fact that
the
chinese the japanese and the europeans
are now looking at
post hill latency physics they're
looking at the next generation of
particle accelerators
which may find who knows supersymmetry
the symmetry of the string
and fifth we're looking for deviations
for newton's laws of gravity
the inverse square law we learned about
in high school gravity diminishes as the
square of the distance
if you're twice the distance gravity
goes down by factor of four
but no one's ever tested that in your
living room
so in outer space in outer space we know
that the inverse square law works for
galaxies
works for stars planets but we don't
know whether it works for your living
room or not
so we're going to test it we're going to
test the inverse squared law to see
whether or not there's a
there's an inverse cubic or inverse
cortic
or quintic corrections to newton's laws
of gravity
so there you have it five experiments
that could be done
to prove that the theory the string
theory is a theory of everything
or a theory of anything or a theory of
nothing
let me ask you another philosophical
question which is that
and i've had this conversation with sir
roger penrose after he won his nobel
prize
i said sir roger you know you and
stephen and and uh others worked on
singularity theorems black holes and uh
origin
singularities of course stephen went
astray in some sense and
and really made this case in the brief
history of time that
that the universe emerged in the
so-called harl hawking state
uh and that time had no boundary and
effectively can be
instantiated uh in what he called a
trick
in the book and a few people really have
read it all the way through because he
says it's a trick
just to think about things
mathematically and then he goes on to
say because of this
the universe doesn't need a beginning
and therefore one of the two roles for
god
has been eliminated in other words god
had two purposes according to stephen
one was to to initiate the universe and
the other one was to
uh instantiate the laws of physics he
said that law
of property number one of god was
invalidated by the no boundary theorem
property number two would be invalidated
in his later book the grand design
via m theory what do you think make of
these two clips first of all
does any practicing theoretical
physicists believe that the
no boundary condition is is accurate in
other words a
physical instantiation of time itself is
now
contains no boundary because of this
wick rotation that he did
uh in the to the complex plane for time
in
uh and and described in a brief history
of time do any of your colleagues in
theoretical physics
actually take that seriously currently
well first of all i have no judge of
hawking's
no boundary theorem i don't work in that
field however to answer your question
am i aware of people who work on it
actively and the answer is no
i don't think personally this is my
personal opinion not objective
my personal opinion is most people think
of it as a curiosity
a mathematical trick you simply add the
square root of minus one to the
equations and boop
your singularity disappears okay it's a
sleight of hand
physics is subtle it's not just a slight
of hand that you can do by putting an
extra i
in your equations you don't make your
equations work just because you put an x
of square root of minus one in the
equations
but again i'm no authority in this field
but to my knowledge no one really takes
it seriously
oh sorry go ahead also hawking had
another
uh argument against the existence of god
he had several
the other one was that the big bang
happened so quickly
that there was no time for god to create
the universe
the universe was simply uh there and uh
you know to create a universe it takes a
lot of work creating universes is not
not easy
and there was no time to create the
universe but you see if string theory is
correct
then there was a pre big bang universe
a universe before the collision of our
universe is to create our
known universe so a bubble bath a
universe is in a bubble bath
bubbles can collide bubbles can fission
so there's a time before the collision
of two universes
so there's a time before the big bang in
string theory
just pivoting a little bit uh i have an
unusual background in that my parents
were both born
jewish biologically jewish i was then uh
baptized in the catholic church and then
i became an altar boy in the catholic
church then i became an
atheist then i became a
practicing jew slash devout agnostic
you have a similar background your
parents were buddhist you were raised
presbyterian
now you call yourself agnostic explain
what agnosticism means
in practice do you do anything that that
theists believe in that they
practice do you go to church or do you
stay home like richard dawkins
well you know some people have tried to
disprove
the existence of god but that's like
trying to disprove the existence of
unicorns
uh you can't do it it's logically
impossible to disprove a negative
so my daughter's room my daughter's
bedroom is full of unicorns
yeah i mean if you even if you say that
we've looked for unicorns and we can't
find unicorns anywhere
somewhere some place that you've never
looked never even thought of looking
could harbor a unicorn so it's very
dangerous to say that some things
don't exist so when some people say that
god doesn't exist you can prove it
well maybe god exists in a place they
didn't look for
now i believe in the god of einstein so
let me explain
einstein did not believe in a personal
god he did not believe that
you know your christmas presents are
given to you because god
wants you to have that bicycle for
christmas you know god doesn't smite the
philistines walk on water or all those
things
but he did believe in the god of spinoza
the god of beauty
harmony elegance simplicity the world
could have been random
that could have the world could have
been chaotic the world could have been
messy the universe could have been awful
but here we
are as conscious beings contemplating
the fact that the laws of physics
can be summarized on one sheet of paper
now it didn't have to be that way our
universe is
gorgeous think of what our universe
could have been
versus what our universe really is we
have conscious life
in a universe that started off in a
random state
and so that's why i think that as
einstein figured
humanity is like a little boy or a girl
going into a library for the first time
and there's this huge storehouse of
knowledge
and all we can do is get the first book
look at the first page read the first
paragraph that's all we can do but in
front of us
there's this ocean of knowledge and it
didn't have to be that way
it could have been messy chaotic ugly
random
but here we are in a universe where the
laws of physics
the ultimate law is you can write on a
sheet of paper in fact i think you can
get it down to one inch
well with my handwriting it would be
hopeless to fit in anything other than
than a poster size format because i have
terrible handwriting
but mitch i want to ask a question is it
not presumptuous since we don't have
even a grand unified
theory that everybody agrees to in other
words we don't we we have candidates
issue 5 we have
t salam we have other candidate theories
as i mentioned
is it presumptuous is it not like going
from say einstein unifying the law of
gravity on earth
to the laws of uh gravity of the moon
you know from apples to
satellites uh is it would it not be like
going from that to
you know the electro weak unification in
other words are we putting
you know the cart before the force a
little bit too much looking for the god
equation
before we find the jesus equi i don't
know the equation just
right below the god equation
well some people talk about a desert
that is if you take a look at the energy
of our particle accelerators
they're low energy we can go to 14
trillion electron volts
and up to that point there's hundreds of
particles that we can
discover some people think that beyond
that
we're going to see a desert almost no
subatomic particles at all now why is
that
because the next energy realm is
the top energy that's 10 to the 19
billion electron volts that is a
quadrillion times more powerful than the
large hedron collider
some pessimists say that from now with
the higgs boson
till the clock energy there's a desert
now we can't rule it out because we
don't know when
supersymmetry kicks in now let me
explain
symmetry is the language of the universe
symmetry allows you to combine two
things that look dissimilar
e equals m c squared for example unifies
e
with m unifies matter with e
and m is the hydrogen of the sun
and e is the sunlight that we get from
the sun
so we look for symmetry now symmetry we
don't know
when super symmetry kicks in people
believe that even the critics of string
theory thinks that supersymmetry may
kick in
has a symmetry of the string
and what energy will it kick in so there
is a criticism that says that
there could be a desert there no matter
how big a particle accelerator we build
we will find nothing just the standard
model
now i don't believe in that but you
can't dismiss it easily
because there are some people who
propose that idea the idea of a desert
um and i've talked with um
with us with sheldon glashow on the
podcast a couple of months
back and he's obviously been been quite
a critic in
in in some ways of uh of the
you know of string theory as it is and
even spoken in terms of
almost presenting a danger i i don't
want to get you know back into that kind
of debate
but um but i do want to think you know
kind of more broadly
when we when we you know think about uh
these these big
items like the existence of a possible
string landscape or the existence of a
multiverse
um you know what what is it about that
that that necessarily connects to god
you know for example
if i go to my neighbor who has a lab
down the hall you know she studies
condensed matter
you know field theory you know particle
uh connects matter
sorry condensed matter phenomenology so
you know she might be looking at
um at you know churn simon's topological
defect matter and so
how come they don't talk about god as
much as as we seem to do in the
cosmology and
fundamental physics theories realm do
well it starts with einstein
in the sense that he said that
religion is lame but religion without
science is blind
and so if you read his works they're
littered with references to god again
not the personal god
the god that you pray to the god that
you want to
give get that bicycle for christmas no
we're not talking about
by that kind of god and the public is
also fascinated by god
just a few years ago on auction the
einstein god letter
went up for auction and people estimated
that if we pull in maybe a few million a
few hundred thousand
people were shocked people were shocked
that that collectors were
willing to pay a million dollars to get
einstein's
god letter where he lays out his
position on god
that he doesn't believe in a personal
god but he does believe in the god of
spinoza so it's out there
now also in mathematics there is a god
equation in mathematics
if you're a mathematician you know that
certain numbers are sacred
1 0
and pi and e these are the secret
numbers of mathematics
there's one equation the euler equation
which summarizes all these fundamental
constants in
one equation that is sometimes called
the god equation
of course is pure mathematics so of what
practical importance is it
nothing for very little anyway because
it's pure math
however think about it for a moment not
equation of physics
on the same scale as the god equation of
mathematics
would unify the fundamental features
of not just math but the universe
because that's what physics is all about
the equations of the universe
and so the fact that there could be a
god equation for physics to me
is astounding absolutely astounding
because there's already a god equation
for mathematics
but a guide equation for physics would
be a theory of
all physical form
[Music]
give rise to you and me give rise to
love
everything that we enjoy about the
universe emerging
from one equation so i want to conclude
uh this second edition of our
you know podcast with kind of just a
brief history
of your time on earth you have an
amazing story you were born
to parents i understand that they were
in interred in in world war ii
uh as citizens it's an awful epoch in
american history um did they ever harbor
resentment towards the government
how did they react on a personal level
if you don't mind describing it
it's such a unique horror in our history
um how did that
did that impact you did it impact them
if you care to talk about that
i would appreciate it well first of all
my parents were u.s citizens
uh my father was born in palo which is
the center of silicon valley today
my mother was born in marysville
california they were both u.s citizens
yeah but nonetheless in 1942
they were locked up and kept behind
barbed wire
kept behind guns kept inside a camp
their funds were pretty much confiscated
you had two weeks
if you were lucky you had two weeks to
liquidate all your assets
and so it was heartbreaking knowing that
your neighbors
your neighbors that you've known for for
a generation
would come up to your house and bid
pennies pennies on the dollar
for all your household heirlooms because
you could only take
what you could carry on your back
so they had to liquidate and again some
people had to liquidate farms
they had to liquidate greenhouses
the japanese were the ones who drained a
lot of the swamp plant of california
and created this bread basket this bread
basket called california
and a lot of it was done by japanese and
after the war they came back
it was all gone they found their
neighbors their neighbors living in
their homes
and of course it was after world war ii
so they really couldn't say much about
it
and the supreme court supreme court even
though individual
justices have spoken against it
to their credit the court itself
has never made a landmark decision
showing that it is unconstitutional so
some
people who are experts in the
constitution say there's a loophole
there
that in case of a crisis uh the mccarran
act
and other acts could be reinstated in
which case
people could just be locked up and put
into the camps by the hundreds of
thousands a hundred ten thousand
japanese americans were incarcerated
during that time
now my parents base their philosophy was
very practical you pick up the pieces
and you move forward
you do not have a chip on your shoulder
of course you want to make sure it
doesn't happen again
you want to make sure it doesn't happen
again but you don't want to have a chip
on your shoulder either
and you want to do your best and
unconsciously
i sort of knew in the back of my mind
that if i was going to be
anything in the world i would have to be
quote extra
i have to give put more on the table
than the average person no one told me
that
but i just sort of figured it out that
if you want to be considered equal
maybe you should be a little better than
equal but like i said
i'm not going to come out with a chip on
my shoulder i think that we learned the
lesson
we have to make sure that the supreme
court unconditionally rules that
uh as unconstitutional while it has not
yet done so
and i think we'll be in a better place
as a consequence
yeah i agree i mean looking at you know
the current climate where
people are going back to the founding
fathers of the country
and and rightfully you know
understanding or wanting to
you know um put in context the fact that
many of them own slaves i mean this is
in the living
memory what happened to as you say u.s
citizens
um and not at all to diminish the
horrors and the uh
moral uh inexcusability of human slavery
uh but this is still within our
generation and yet president you know
roosevelt
is held up with such high esteem and and
so forth by by many members of society
i don't feel like we reckon with that
with what we did to our fellow citizens
back then
and but i do want to you know uh
compliment you and and your spirit
which you know immediately went to uh
you
being you know constructing a a particle
accelerator not far
from uh uc berkeley where the the
particle accelerator
was born as a young person and maybe
maybe we can close out with that because
one thing i usually ask my guests is do
you think that creativity michio
can it be taught were you born with
these
kind of creative uh abilities did you
have to work extremely hard at this this
is something neil degrasse tyson took me
to task for
essentially criticizing you know the
assumption that oh he was just born with
a gift were you born with a gift were
you born with
the ability to do hard work which i
consider a gift would you attribute your
success in terms of your creativity
and throughput as a scientist
well my philosophy is first of all we
are all born scientists
we're born wondering where we came from
why the stars shine
why the sun shines we can't help it
we're just born
scientists until we hit the greatest
destroyer
of scientists known to science the
greatest destroyer
of scientists known to science is junior
high school
when you go to junior high school
science has made boring
science has made memorization is being
having to know things that are totally
irrelevant to people's lives you know in
the back of your mind
you're never going to use that piece of
knowledge ever again and you're
more or less right science is not
relevant to people
and science becomes giving names to
things uh
richard feynman the nova laureate told
this story that when he was a child
his father would take him into the
forest and show him
uh how how birds evolved coloration
big how they feed and so and so forth
and one day a bully comes up to
feynman and basically says hey dick
what's the name of that bird over there
and the young feynman did not know the
name of the bird so i'll paraphrase
the bully then says what's the matter
dick you stupid or something
and in that instant feynman realized the
difference between
science and the appearance of science
the science is about principles
concepts physical models and pictures
that's what science is about not giving
the names to birds of course you have to
know some names
but that is not science giving the names
to things
and so i think that's something that we
have to realize
that young children were born scientists
until it's crushed out of them
crushed out of them when they hit junior
high school
reminds me of a joke that i sometimes
tell where i took a
class in ornithology as an undergraduate
at case western reserve university and
we studied hard their migration habits
their mating habits their
you know their their dietary habits all
these things about birds or evolution
and then the final exam came and all
that was on the test were
uh bird prince and we were supposed to
identify this bird from its bird track
that looks like this and this one and
birds have almost
all the same footprints at least in
phenotype
so to speak and i got so frustrated
michio that i handed in my paper
and i didn't put my name on it in this
huge class of 150 students
and as i'm storming out fuming mad the
professor says
wait wait you didn't write your name on
it and i said
professor figure it out
i held up my foot um he didn't laugh and
you're not laughing either but that's
okay uh not all of my jokes are
so spectacular but michio what is
spectacular is your book the god
equation
a best seller in the new york times a
bestseller on amazon
hundreds of thousands of people are
going to be exposed to concept that
is mind-blowing but presented by one of
the foremost experts the person who
came up if you if you're out there my
audience is expert
he basically michio i think i can brag
for you you came up with the feynman
diagram type
exposition for strings back in the early
70s i mean when string theory was a
newborn
we talked about its umbilical cord well
the umbilical cord goes straight through
michio kaku
the father of string field theory the
governing lagrangian
the space-time tube diagrams the feynman
diagrams there are 11 of them in your
original beautiful paper
which is a work of art by the way in a
time when it was very difficult to make
art
and uh illustrations and papers but
mitch i want to thank you so much
for your graciousness your generosity
with your time this our second interview
i'm going to try to salvage some of the
previous one
but i want to especially commend you on
this wonderful new book the god equation
and i'll let you know when this
interview comes out but for now
i want to know i want you to know how
much of a positive wonderful impact
you've had on my multiverse
thank you it's a real honor being on
your program
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you